in five four three two everybody welcome
to the genius brain podcast we got my
boy Kelly Boyd up in here today yeah
that's super flexible now this one
flexible man I've ever seen in my life I
could see it I could hear his knees
creak right now I had no idea you were
that unflexible yeah man it contributes
to my hops it does though like the tight
muscles it's like that the fast twitch
in my checker jump I could yeah you have
like that fast which if I got wound up
and you can [ __ ] go yeah I do there
was a talks about I forgot who I was
talking no I wasn't talking to this
person it was an interview with this guy
named Frank Yeager and he was talking
about one of my favorite fighters in the
UFC called
his name is SN Barbosa he's a really
fast switch kick up really quick and if
you would think that he's very flexible
because of how flexible hips are and how
he can kick but he was talking about
he's actually not flexible at all like
we were stretching each other while they
were while they were you know training
and it says like dude he can't stretch
for [ __ ] we're so surprising but because
his muscles are so tight his switch
kicks like one of the fastest in the UFC
that's his advantage
yeah that's bad exactly so you could be
a good farm poser switch kick you could
do a [ __ ] fast a twitch kick if you
get that [ __ ] down no [ __ ] loose well
[ __ ] now we're talking this training you
know so basically today we already know
what we're gonna talk about and we gonna
talk about the Jordan documentary I love
it is the Jordan documentary yeah what's
the actual name though the last dance
the last [ __ ] dance I've been putting
off watching this for the longest time
number one it's not because I didn't
think it was gonna be good I just didn't
want to watch something that was gonna
make me feel bad about myself
where did warrior or what were your
expectations
I just isn't me on some David Goggin
[ __ ] just don't make me feel like I'm a
piece of [ __ ] Yeah right and it did
[ __ ] [ __ ] I watched be the pot the
podcast I watched the doc and the first
episode alone it already showed you how
different Jordan is for
every other [ __ ] human being and how
hard it is to match that standard
because originally because Kobe is more
of our generation I mean Jordan was
still our general but we were really
really really young yeah yeah we caught
him towards like the tail end for one
the stuff that I could remember of
Jordan it was towards the tail end of
his career yeah
everything else is like recaps or NBA
classics right and that's kind of what
reopen my memory about the stuff that he
did or some like all heads talking about
him but Kobe was that to us right we
look at Kobe's work ethic and you know
he'd the way he would you know [ __ ] dude
I read this funny ass article and it was
it was them recounting so Jeremy Lin was
on as a Danny Green is his podcast oh
yeah yeah he has his podcast right and
he was talking about how Kobe hurt
himself I think he tore his labrum or a
shoulder or whatever and he was going
into practice
he hasn't been in practice in a while
this is a Carlos Boozer I was in was in
the Lakers and so I guess they assumed
that he was coming to practice you know
to say bye to the people who were gonna
get cut he's like I just want to say
goodbye to the losers getting traded
this is okay came to practice say
goodbye to the losers that are getting
traded cuz they're [ __ ] weak
that's Kobe Bryant yeah and and then you
know we talk about that relationship
that he had with like Jeremy Lin and him
in that moment where he grabbed the way
he got pissed because either Jeremy was
gonna pass the ball or he was gonna foul
somebody he wanted but knows because he
was the coach told him not to lose Byron
Scott a forever dude Andy is a binary
Scott was it Byron Scott no what is it I
can't remember who was coaching at the
time but he was instructed not to and
then Kobe told him to so that's like the
weird dynamic that they have is like
when Kobe is on court
he's [ __ ] coach what he says is law
yeah but then you know Jeremy Lin he's
like coaches coach right so he's like
Kobe just [ __ ] got him you know lo
and behold there's a reason why that
happened yeah yeah it literally came
back to tell people that are [ __ ]
loser
so funny that's how intense he is and
then you look at that man who you look
at who Kobe is and then Kobe says in the
doc now when he came up I'm all Daniel
shut its you know I didn't expect guys
that's Coby and he goes I hate it when
people ask me who would win uh who would
win in a one-on-one me or Jordan in his
prime I was like you know he's like even
if I did think that or whatever it's so
disrespectful to even have that
conversation because there is no Kobe if
there wasn't Jordan I asked him for
advice he coached me on my game when he
passed away Jordan was talking about his
2:00 a.m. in the [ __ ] morning and
Kobe's asking me how to improve my
dodgeball game you know yeah so that
that that comparison was so
disrespectful one of the things I didn't
realize too was the disrespect of Pippen
the disrespect I mean how the his
contract uh yeah yeah well cuz I there
is little blurbs about like Skype Ivins
livid about the depiction of him and the
last dance but I also rhetorical that
Jordan was it paid well either in terms
of this contract like a long-term
contract and he never once went back to
man dressed like I deserved more he's
all about basketball which is weird but
yeah Pippen that was at the time that he
was signed from what I read mmm he was
like the 16th highest paid person right
heaven yeah Pippen which was great that
was only at the time that he was paid
right because he was a rookie mhm and so
I guess the extension of his contract
didn't include his rookie years I mean
I'm not sure exactly what it was but it
wasn't really seven years total like
nine because I didn't include the rookie
years and so he kind of extended longer
but it was seven years for whatever that
many millions right so there wasn't know
how big of a star he was going to become
signing that he was advised not to sign
that contract but because of the
situation that he was in here that what
a 10-person family or something when his
dad's in a wheelchair one of his
brothers is like Parana been a co any
kind of surgery was career-ending
exactly so he was injured and he wasn't
sure that he was gonna play better than
he was going to now if you don't want to
take that risk
right which a lot of people advised him
not to take that contract but he was
kind of put in my family exactly yeah
but the the contract was [ __ ]
terrible yeah it was was 1718 Millford a
mere eight years like this it was so
ridiculous for the best years of his
life yeah now after his
Chicago Bulls contract and he went over
to rocket the Rockets and I think got
like a twenty five million dollar deal
for like two years
yeah you played one year exactly so it
kind of made up for it but it was rough
because watching in the documentary he
was kind of fed up with it he went head
to head with all the GM's and huge
[ __ ] eyes Dorfman it was hard to watch
yeah that was really tough it's so funny
cause it's like I guess there's like a
joke about they call
Pippen was it Pippen no tipping or
tipping tipping tipping no tipping
tipping tipping because he was notorious
for not paying tips oh really now a
Chicago like [ __ ] it's been thousands of
dollars never leave a tip but Jordan was
awesome not to be like that I think I
forgot who there's like all these
stories about like Jordan like one of
the teammates was giving a homeless
person um money and he got mad at okay
so why are you giving him money he could
work at McDonald's if you wanted to yeah
I was like okay cool Pam then well
that's their mentality yeah that's
that's Ned how do you infer gala T that
is their personality of yeah people need
to work for their [ __ ] yeah that's it is
yeah that's him to the T dude just
watching him work especially as a young
/ - the [ __ ] was that I said that yeah I
was better than Jordan James what were
they James Worthy that's the Jordan two
weeks 21 year old Jim being 21 if I can
like you know he was so competitive like
another story about him being like after
every practice he will write a number on
the drive board and be like all right be
like six I did I dumped on you Sam
Perkins three times and Eugene's worthy
three times that so many times I don't
do you guys just like that's crazy yeah
watching watching him go through the
whole Pistons saga
I barely read it was yeah I didn't
realize how much of a [ __ ] bully they
were they were [ __ ] they didn't
hunched and elbowing
him you know what's the funny part about
that [ __ ] it's like because I don't
remember this I can't speak for it but
form of the documentary saying or what
people were called
number one Jordan still pissed about it
mmm you could tell he's still emotional
about that sure he was yeah it's like
they didn't win by basketball skill they
won by psychology yeah it's like we're
gonna piss you off and get you off their
game and that's how they want right and
you know there's so many and I'm you of
Isaiah Thomas being an [ __ ] because
that was his thing right he's like um
leader of the bellboys he's the original
Chris Paul neither help money just more
savage cuz he's a tiny dude that would
just [ __ ] hurt people on call yeah
right never know who the [ __ ] he [ __ ]
up I said how much yeah he made somebody
bleed on court really bad really I can't
remember I think there was like a
picture of it back in the day but there
was that one part in the dock where god
Jordan was a how long here we're [ __ ]
yesterday yeah and they showed him a
clip of what he's taught me on stuff
that's what's that right there yeah cuz
I said Thomas was things in [ __ ]
yeah back in the day when it was
basketball when he came there wasn't
there was no spoor ship nobody shook
hands he goes it's a clip of Jordan he
lost
yeah because it's [ __ ] he's made it
yeah he still hates Isaiah Thomas yeah
terrible time it's a terrible time to
you know not shake his hand and then
have the Olympics come up and not be
included in the dream team oh that's
right yeah that's right yeah which is
funny cos Chuck Daly was who was the
coach of the Pistons he was a coach out
of the dream team yeah so not to have
his star on the dream team it was like
what was said yeah yeah yeah yeah
that dream team was amazing about doing
one of the best dream teams you've been
watching that stuff and watching all
these players that I used to watch
[ __ ] Jason Kidd when he was on the
Suns I was like oh [ __ ] I was like
that's weird
yeah right as I'm not you see man that
stuns Jersey and I forgot about that
[ __ ] hmm yeah watching all these players
kind of come back I didn't know about
that one of the one German dude Kukoc
Kukoc not a German dude it wasn't Kukoc
it was the guy that died in the car
accident
I remember that player dying but I
didn't remember what his relationship
was to Chicago it was I'm not sure if he
was too but he died in Germany and he
they played him in the Olympics and they
were gonna get picked up and this is
during the time that they were going
through negotiations with Pippen and
they were worried more about
this kind of they're gonna pick up in
Germany or wherever it wasn't Kukoc it
was it was Oh weird
why not remember this yeah and it was in
the duct and they were talking about how
he he was they never won against he they
never won against although this is cool
I'm mixing a cuckoo historian somebody
else this he was a part of I'm not sure
if it was the Pistons or whatever but he
was going against Jordan all the time it
was Jordan and um oh [ __ ] I might mix me
this up right now i watch this is such a
blur it was it was a player that oh it
wasn't Dave he wasn't on Chicago I'm
mixing up Kukoc and this guy but he was
if I could remember his [ __ ] name but
he would play against Jordan like
internationally right hmm um he was an
international player I forgot what team
he was a part of but they would go back
and forth and they they called him like
the next Jordan huh
right they never won a game game against
Jordan ever right but he was so
tenacious like there was a lot of
respect for him but he actually passed
away from from a car accident while he
was in Germany I remember I remember
this death my phone and even on me right
now but that that that part was like
pretty crazy okay that was a part of the
documentary I rented that up after I
don't think that was in DINO Kukoc
though yeah yeah they were putting good
on him dude yeah [ __ ] yes like a [ __ ]
was talking about Scottie Pippen's voice
dobro [ __ ] look he just woke up yeah
what did he like about his depiction on
the documentary was it is it one of
those blurbs I don't know if it's real
or not I don't know why he would even be
mad because it looked like bad yeah cuz
Jordan said like there's no Jordan or
not pimpin yes the best teammate he's
ever played with and maybe he was mad
because John was like Scotty was wrong
for that [ __ ] when he took that rest off
for the summer Japan yeah maybe maybe
Hornet dude that the doc is so real mmm
cuz they're cursing left and right they
don't give a [ __ ]
Horace Grant I guess Horace Grant didn't
like the way you was too big yeah yeah
yeah cuz of the dad book by Sam Smith
the Jordan rules mmm yeah Journal rules
talking about like what goes on behind
the scenes of the you know championship
Chicago Bulls and Jordan thought that
horse ground was leaking information
oh stuff that was sacred to the locker
room to this reporter cuz it's known a
horse and Sam Smith for a good friends
my horse was like I understand it's as
private I would never get the coaches
that could have been a coaching
assistant could have been the you know
Jimmy could have anybody but Jordan was
like in the doctor is like all that was
course I was horse and then cutsie horse
like I never did that yeah yeah so that
was interesting to have them at at that
end when you watch that when you watch
the doc right and you see kind of his
struggles as an NBA player does it make
you want to play ball again like
Superbad this podcast is brought to you
by skill share what is Skillshare you
ask it is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning
Skillshare offers classes designed for
real life so you can learn the things
you want at your pace based on your busy
routine see now I know a lot of people
out there that want to make films for
fun or maybe even as a side hustle see
there's a lot of classes to take that
skill show offers that I know that a lot
of you would enjoy right now and I've
actually moved on to a course called
iPhone filmmaking my favorite course
because when I travel I don't like large
equipment so I kind of want to utilize
what I have which is my phone and make
it look as cinematic as possible and
this course is really fun and really
dope explore your creativity and get two
free months of premium membership at
Skillshare comm slash brain that's two
whole months of unlimited access that
thousands of classes for free get
started and joined today by heading to
Skillshare comm slash brain that's two
three months of unlimited access to
thousands of classes at Skillshare comm
slash brain it does to spend initially
it did and then as you got to peel back
the layers and see Jordan to how like I
said earlier like that dudes like a
sociopath yeah like and you know his
like he's addicted to competition like
I don't know if I could wake up before
the Sun comes up and be at it
yeah I'm trained and do all that stuff
but definitely makes me wanna play
basketball that's for sure but not at
the high level that I used to it's weird
watching somebody dedicate themselves so
seriously to one craft for the rest of
their life cuz I don't know what that
feels like that's something that I I'm
envious of like to be able to laser
focus on one thing because you don't see
Jordan you know out there playing the
guitar you don't see him [ __ ]
learning how to be a jabbawockee issue
but if you wanted to watch I bet you
never wanna [ __ ] away yeah I'm pretty
sure if you came to Jordan you said you
could never be a Jabbawockeez oh yeah
like who is that tall last month that's
John you know yeah just like the Chicago
White Sox story in that bit they want oh
that's right yeah and his indomitable
spirit to do to excel at something is
insane it
I think this doc is gonna win so many
[ __ ] awards for sure for facts
I mean integrity is kind of close tired
King up there the baton King was just
more like value yeah he's weird yeah
this is more of like the behind this
things that we always wanted to know
about during this whole saga right
because I know stuff about Jordan is so
secret and see him so emotional in some
parts yeah he was angry he's still angry
like it was yesterday
yeah he was talking about [ __ ]
a [ __ ] ain't gonna do nothing to me yeah
man I won't part when you like I'm just
tearing it up here's like it's just the
way I play if you don't play that way my
mindset this is how I play you don't
want to you don't have to cut yeah
that's like a man we're saying cut that
[ __ ] I really wanted to see where he
would go after that I think I you know a
part of me makes me feel that because of
how Jordan is as a human being and
because he's so unique I think he also
feels a little alone oh for sure oh for
sure dude every time you want a
championship or like just seeing him
like won his father passed away and they
won that championship during the
father's first day like him on the floor
all the cameras around him or like when
he won the championship and all his he's
playing the piano
like all these reporters and like
another championship he's just in the
hallway like sitting there like smoking
cigar like there's no family so no
really for him he had its dad yeah
fortune and you know some friends but
for the most part yeah right it didn't
seem like you have friends it's I think
it's hard for people to relate to him
right because they can't really connect
to him like that they can connect and
relate to him in the sense of when they
win the championship there's victory and
all this other stuff but how do you
connect to somebody at that level of
greatness who the word isn't better but
it's more like they have a higher sense
of of of success right they have a very
specific goal that they're always trying
to meet and everything else that's not
towards that goal just falls through the
wayside I mean I don't know what his
family life is like with his kid or
anything else yeah but I'm pretty sure
that it from what it seems like when
he's talking about the stuff is like he
seems very lonely mm-hmm I could be
wrong you know and that shouldn't be
observing from the outside yeah I
definitely got that sense yeah it's like
he is his own dragon like yeah you know
just because I have those stories about
how committed how competitive he is with
his kids
even when they were young like tackling
them and breaking glass and [ __ ] like on
accident cuz he's super competitive
playing football with his kids God
answered crazy stories like that I
forgot what what radio station they his
kids went on and his son was not that
good at ball yeah yeah Jeffrey R Marcus
name yeah and I was disappointed yeah
yeah I mean Jordan so Chris is it cuz
Jordan wasn't supposed to happen that's
the crazy thing but yes like the famous
story he got cut from his high school
team Stockmann yeah that's the best
thing that could have happened cries
tells his mom Dolores Dolores is like
you don't stop your kid you either get
bitter or you could get better yeah
better and then he wasn't like top 200
top 50 top 20 he wasn't like top any
player in North Carolina like he would
have to be snuck into like these
all-star camps because
his coach knew somebody and believed he
was the next thing but yeah in terms of
like SoCal hoops or whatever ranking
systems like rivals.com
like ranking high schoolers like Jordan
was not on there so he literally came
out of nowhere
yeah literally came out of nowhere and
then became when he became I feel like
that fool was like anointed by God or
something he he yeah it's odd justice
sees the trajectory that he went on and
from that one conversation from his mom
it's like get better and get better than
those got it welcome to the space from
that the better he I didn't even know
that Nike was a no-name brand yeah yeah
Jordan was the one that single-handedly
it brought up Nike yeah that's [ __ ]
insane converse was the biggest shoe
brand out there for any NBA player with
that corny ass [ __ ] rap with uh yeah
I wonder what I say I got the shoes on
my feet and that's my day that was the
weird thing watching that whole I was I
had no idea I knew that Converse Chuck
Taylors were the first original
basketball shoe I didn't know that they
dominated the shoe like the basketball
shoe sport
you would never know that [ __ ] because
it's always been Nike it's always been
adidas yeah and that was the end of the
conversation right yeah yeah Jordan came
at the time it was such a was the were
like hizmet yeah for uh all of that cuz
like the league was okay like that bird
and magic and then like these Jordan
like this hot thing from North Carolina
and no one's seen anything like that and
like converse like don't even want to go
to Nike go to what Dita's or something
like that yeah and in converse was only
gonna pay him like a hundred thousand
hmm and Nike was like [ __ ] will pay two
hundred fifty thousand just where his
where as [ __ ] and at that time his agent
was saying like they came out this new
technology called the air soles just
that's the guy was like right or Jordan
than it is in
I'm Spike Lee and like which I thought
was so interesting with that because
Spike Lee is strongly associated with
the hip-hop community and mm-hmm just
black you know - black community and I
wish in the documentary they would have
explored more about like Jordans
relationship with african-american
community cuz he's been notorious about
not being vocal about it yeah
and I do understand because they talked
about like that harvey gantt situation
where like they want him to endorse that
politician and he was like cool I don't
get into that I'm just a basketball
player like you know I agree with that
he like if someone was like hey you
what's your opinion about this
I don't know cuz I had a million
followers just like that like I don't
know I don't have the experience the
study you know I'm not qualified for
this so with with Jordan just go back to
Jordan just like them to take that risk
on this rookie who has nothing on his
resume and then expect three million and
they get 250 or 20 million it is odd it
is so he is an alien yeah like he's like
those secret Illuminati triangles you
see him yeah bills and [ __ ] like yeah I
don't he makes no sense to me yeah it's
I kind of I just didn't understand I
don't understand - when okay I get it I
get it in the sense of I feel like even
that if if for something that's more
current for us mmm any black knew that
didn't support Obama you were an Uncle
Tom okay [ __ ] mmm a [ __ ] if you care
about his policy or whatever I'm not
saying this this is this is not mean I
don't know anything about Obama I know
nothing about politics that's why every
time I talk about politics Josey or Joe
Stalin politics all day I know [ __ ]
nothing
hmm I if somebody asked me how how I
don't know what Bill is put into this
into play see I don't know the
terminology I'll be like I have no
[ __ ] clue I'm one of those laymen's
I'm one of those people that pays his
taxes and lives the American dream but
if you ask me anything about government
[ __ ] it's hard for me to have an opinion
about something I don't know about which
is so funny because when you say when
you talk about Jordan saying hey I'm
just a basketball player
we fast forward now to today's current
climate right everyone now every
celebrity is expected to have an opinion
about what's going on in politics when
it's something they know nothing about
right and they almost feel like they
have to say something even though
they're not that knowledgeable about the
subject right because I forgot who said
it - who's that blonde blonde white lady
that stuff that was a Fox reporter not
Ann Coulter but she was people say she
was hot she's like blonde she's very
loud very angry you know who I'm talking
about right yeah yeah I think the damn
movie about her show yeah she was think
yeah but she says a lot of crazy [ __ ]
right she's like super angry she was
super good laughs oh now her that's not
hurt that's different yeah how about
that but yeah anything about but her she
was the one that was telling you know
LeBron James to just be a ballplayer
right dribble yeah shut up and dribble
which is kind of what Jordan was sayings
like I just dribble right right I know
so much mm where people want or you know
celebrities to have an opinion about
these certain subjects like every time
some kind of like hot negative topic
comes out about the Asian community like
you'll do a [ __ ] video on this and
I'm like I can but I need time to think
and let me research the stuff first
before I go ahead and form an opinion
about this cuz things changing every 20
minutes I don't [ __ ] know can create
that I always tell people to when you
want me to do a video about this Asian
these Asian topics that you know it's
very disparaging on Asian people you got
to realize too if I'm doing of it every
[ __ ] minute where I'm yelling and I'm
screaming and I'm angry it's exhausting
on my spirit like I I get affected by
that [ __ ] I'm exhausted I can't watch
videos of [ __ ] old Asian ladies can
beat all the time keep putting out these
videos that you guys already know about
this stuff I'm not saying I'm gonna give
up but what I'm saying is is that to
expect me to be to pounce on any kind of
topic that has to do with any Asian like
disparaging Asian content I would be
doing that every [ __ ] day for every
second of my life and then I would die
like cutting yourself yeah every day it
would just be me sitting here doing
content about oh did you see this video
about this other Asian person that was
called a [ __ ] monster when he was
eating a cookie first I would laugh and
would be like yeah what the [ __ ] that's
kind of [ __ ] up like I said I'm not
you know my best friend said this
yesterday he goes you're you're more of
a comic than you are anything else is
because when I when we were having the
conversation about the one lady who was
in the White House I forgot what her
political position is but she said that
there was a couple of people in the
White House they said that she had
become flu and the first thing I did was
laugh my ass off I died laughing I said
the come flute that's [ __ ] funny oh
that's a that's a good ass dish and I
was cracking the [ __ ] huh and then when
I was reading that I read everybody else
calm still like how dare they I was like
oh I missed the mark on this one I'm not
in the majority here man right that's
why I need to sit and simmer on things
cuz you laugh about because when people
thought up the argument right big oh oh
when uh when the when Ebola came out
they they called the African virus yes
they did yeah [ __ ] that was
drying already bola Joe you look at one
episode of wild and out and Michael
Blackson on it that [ __ ]
yeah so if when you make that comparison
yet trust me when a bullet came out they
were making a hell bola viruses that was
like the go to [ __ ] you saw one
dark-skinned dude they're like boom
Ebola don't share water with them yeah
move away and that disease by the way
when you get that [ __ ] you're dead yeah
that's it Oh bleeding through your eyes
it was [ __ ] crazy so you know when
people have like if somebody came out to
you on the street those subhanak plague
first I would I was not my living
laughing I'm my [ __ ] that's that's good
I'm like okay you just got him dude
that's yeah pretty [ __ ] funny yeah I
don't know I when I I have a weird sense
of humor I'm pretty sure there's some
other people that laugh about that [ __ ]
when they heard a [ __ ] flume that's don't
even scare that like and then going back
to like well
badge like castle badge whatever or
cancel somebody and like who sometimes I
would like somebody's being cancelled
like the last thing looks like cancel
Chris Evans like do you ever get 7 what
a Chris Evans did that I couldn't dude I
was going through that damn time I was
like what did he do and everyone say I'm
like Captain America yeah but I couldn't
find why he was being canceled like this
hold these all these like kpop stands
you know and all of them haven't the
power to like create you know the number
one trending topic and Austin it's like
why are people people the kpop can be
we're mad at him but for no reason
there's like there's nothing out there
like someone just started it and just
became wildfire well here's the thing
like people who like Korean music - they
don't even like kpop stands there
there's just extreme reaction of people
like these trolls right they're not even
trolled there guys are [ __ ] losers
okay cool that's what you guys are you
know why it's gonna win after you making
my culture look bad I'm [ __ ] like
that's that's what it is right because
it's big the comparison is [ __ ] dumb
they go you don't know what BTS did for
me they saved my life okay that's what
they did for you that's
fan-fucking-tastic here's the thing
nobody has to [ __ ] like the thing is
you [ __ ] like you dumb [ __ ] loser
scary things they're so many oh yeah
they're like they saved my life well so
did the [ __ ] meal I hate yesterday
right I didn't eat that [ __ ] meal I
probably would have died and shut the
[ __ ] up the problem is is that your mate
you're attaching this is not just kpop
stands these are people who are fanatics
of stuff like this right you think that
people should feel a certain way about
something that you enjoy the same way
that you do and if they don't they don't
like it they think that what you do is
dumb you think that they that you are no
Press Group mmm you think that you are
putting yourselves like well why can't
you just let me like the stuff that I
like you can but people can also have
opinion about the stuff that you like as
well that's life that's why you're a
loser you don't understand that people
you can like it and also people can
dislike you that's just a part of it now
it becomes a problem when you know
people bully you about that of course
right
but for
to go out your way and say the reason
why people can't [ __ ] on your stuff is
because you don't know the positive
impact that they've had on your lives in
other people's lives you could say that
about anything I could tell you about
the positive impact that [ __ ] this
brioche bun I had today had on my life
but if you went out your waist if [ __ ]
ríos buns am I gonna cry about it it's
like you know like brioche I whatever
you're a [ __ ] loser and I'm you know
we're not talking just about kpop Stan's
like you're transferring this emotion
about stuff that you shouldn't you
shouldn't do that about anything right
you're putting your identity into a
fandom of an of these people you don't
[ __ ] know to music that's your
identity your identity is in you you're
investing all this time into something
that doesn't help you grow as an
individual you're just these stands -
they they have these fan things where
they just give them money every [ __ ]
month they buy all their stuff and they
support their fan group and all this
other stuff and they do that because
they're hoping that they'll recognize
them for their like I know it's I get it
I trust me I understand we do get help
from the things that we fan from right
there's people that I appreciate that I
donate to their patreon because I
appreciate what they do but if somebody
went out their way and they said you
know what [ __ ] that guy I'm like that's
cool
you ain't gotta like it Yeah right it's
just a scary thing when I see you know
young people they identified themselves
in somebody else rather than fighting
this person over here they don't develop
as human beings you know right because
those those little boy bands they'll
disappear they cycle every five to six
years and they're gone maybe even less
on average even less right before BTS it
was um it was the most that group the
the the Taeyang and all them know I
don't know the name but there was one
before that that was one before that
there was one before that hey Timothy
hey Jyothi was the og right
he's all these other brands right see I
know what's up I'm in the know okay know
what I don't what's poppin right but you
know this is like 1999 mm-hmm I know
[Laughter]
no I know what's going on my name is
weird man I was a huge for okay and
listen I say this from personal
experience right I was so [ __ ] dumb
right remember the Reebok pumps mm-hm
I genuinely believed that if my parents
bought me Reebok pumps I was going to
fly really I thought that I could dunk
after I heard about the elder okay my
man young dude that's fine but still I
say I understand that right moving in
something like that that I believed that
these Reebok pumps if I put them on my
shoes [ __ ] we're gonna get
their ankles left on these and I jumped
and I didn't and I was pissed all that
[ __ ] it didn't [ __ ] happen right I
remember just wearing Jordans I was like
yo when I get when I get my head like a
pair of Jordans on you better believe
number one ankles getting snap and
they're a pair of Jordans I had some
used ones oh damn
yeah I had these low top Jordan ones
this is like I never got like the
original [ __ ] right yeah because by the
time I could afford like Jordans for
real for real and I was saving up money
for it it was I was told by then like 17
18 yeah dad never let me you never
bought me Jordans I wanted Jordans
though I had Nike Air Max is though
those oh really yeah huh what the [ __ ]
were you playing ball in and once
Oh a little dope my damn ones yeah and
ones and no fear above the rim do you
murmur above the rim a TR no I don't
know that [ __ ] oh god yeah I like how
your dad wanted you to play pro ball but
he wouldn't buy you any kicks yeah dude
the closest I got Air Jordans were like
the team won Jordans and only because
Eddie Jones was rocking them I was like
I like those and Eddie Jones wears them
and our Jordan so that's
like I got um yeah I just I was the
first Dornan that I ever got I remember
I got those Air Max 90 s the one with
the bubbles all the way through it yeah
and I I got them at a Nike factory
outlet and this was around the time and
the reason why I remember this is
because so we were broke for a majority
of my life right and then the business
finally started turning around when I
was like around junior high and they and
this Nike outlet opened where things
were like [ __ ] 30% off 40% off and my
mom was like let's go get you some nice
shoes and I remember the Jordan that the
air maxes that I got they had the green
bubble laced through it it was like neon
green bubble
it was it was I felt so [ __ ] fly dude
I wore that [ __ ] so I wear that the ball
I wore that to sleep I did everything
with that [ __ ] then and then lo and
behold you were a shoe so much the
bottom soul started [ __ ] going
through Hubble cracked I was so [ __ ]
sad
but it was great those shoes like we're
a huge part of my identity like number
one it made you the cool kid when you
had dope kicks mmm you had amazing shoes
you were the [ __ ] dope this person in
school I remember in high school I got
these [ __ ] white Air Force Ones and I
was like man those cleaners [ __ ] damn I
yeah yeah that's what I thought I
thought that [ __ ] was [ __ ] tight and
then I remember I was one of the first
[ __ ] they got these all-black
Air Force Ones and it was [ __ ] mr.
cool guy again yeah that's not kicking
[ __ ] Wow
no same being different on my [ __ ]
boat yeah I used to love and then I had
these these black leather timberlands
man I wasn't the big issue I don't know
what it was by these timberlands dude
and then I remember my feet started
growing cuz I was like 10 and a half now
and when I was like 15 and then when I
was 16 I went to like 11 and then I
couldn't fit the the 10 and a half's
anymore like 10 and a half or tens and
there was super tight on my feet and I
was like [ __ ] man I can't wear these but
they were still dope they're still fly I
wore that [ __ ] I just scrunch my toes in
that bin oh yeah and as and I started
binding my feet yeah just to put that
[ __ ] like a little Japanese geisha yeah
and I just put my into my dad got so mad
because he started saying hump for all
my feet work cuz I had a walk back home
I had a walk to school and back might as
I throw those shoes looking at your feet
yeah he was like throw those shoes like
they don't and he was like you need to
throw those shoes away I said I'm not
throwing them away these are dope like I
bought this put the money that saved up
because they don't fit you throw your
shoes away I was like why does it matter
there's everyone Hughes I bought them
why that [ __ ] took those shoes and he
threw grab that went outside and threw
them in the garbage man throwing a
[ __ ] phone wire I was pissed
oh man I was so [ __ ] mad I was livid
how did he do this I don't know I don't
know why he did that I was still wearing
the shoe even though it was a little
tight he goes they don't fit you don't
wear those shoes my dad was such an
[ __ ] back in the day oh yeah then my
mom got so mad at him she's like why do
you [ __ ] care like let him wear the
shoes he goes it doesn't fit him she
goes who the [ __ ] cares are you gonna
buy him new shoes he goes I'll buy him
new shoes never bought me new shoes
those [ __ ] shoes away and in bi
meaning your shoes that's a lot of hurt
but shoes wear a huge part of your
identity mitt if you had like the
hottest Jordans at the time I remember
that when the Aqua eights came out I
have no idea I remember the ones I had
the hologram and the bubble oh you
talking about the the Elevens probably
yeah I remember when Darren Freeman got
them just asking man
but while I wanna be daring freeze-up
mother one where it looks like a quilted
patch on it right yeah yeah yeah my
Jordans anymore man
I remember him you guys can correct me
you guys are sneaker heads now I'm not a
sneaker a team I don't [ __ ] remember
I don't follow sneakers the only the
Jordans that I like are the only ones I
[ __ ] with I don't know all them all the
way through
I like the the fives the ones fours they
were kind of a but threes so one three
the fives Olympics which they were the
seven Olympics the sevens they look at
the Dream Team the one with oh yeah and
I said yeah I saw them when I saw the
documentary's like those are dope I
remember you having those yeah no no
that is my favorite [ __ ] pair the
Olympics there's no [ __ ] dope huh no
no helicopter but really if you go ball
in shoes the those that this that would
be the one to ballin really out of all
the Olympics yeah they're actually don't
bother shoes yeah and then about the
Robins Robins Rodman oh the rapid ramen
soup it terrible this [ __ ] sundial
yeah [ __ ] terrible whose shoe was it
who came out not Stephon Marbury em the
strawberries talked they were so bad
dude like 10 bucks a pop they were
destroying kids beats and you know
what's the funniest [ __ ] thing you
guys can probably look this up is when
we calm the strawberries this
[ __ ] debuted it and the day he
played in it he rolled his ankle because
the shoe was so bad but yo bless his
soul because he was saying that yo it
only cost $10 to manufacture these
[ __ ] shoes so we should be able to
give good ball and shoes to kids who
need it but too bad your shoes were
trashed and they were [ __ ] up
people's ankles kids there were terrible
shoes yeah the best ball of shoe that
you want to that you can get that's
affordable are the adidas the pro styles
oh the pro model baby come on up
Romano's man's role models are still
like 90 bucks
Averroes those are probably my favorite
playing in college right yeah those are
doe great indoor shoes you could still
get them you can still get profit pro
style
about the gel Pro models the probe I
stopped at the Nike Adidas store in New
York they had a whole row I think my
behind those yeah I was also thinking
about buying team eggs why cashews
you're the [ __ ] boat dog it's so bad
I remember when he said LeBron James a
pair like the green and though yeah did
you get the am ones because of [ __ ]
Iverson oh yeah for sure their answers I
wanted to be Iverson still bells too
slow for that [ __ ] dude he was
amazing to watch yeah dude there's so
many people in the NBA that maybe you
guys probably don't remember that was
supposed to be really great but due to
injury they couldn't make it what's his
name [ __ ] magic from from Bernie and
for any hard way dude yeah [ __ ] Penny
Hardaway dude they called him the next
Jordan and an injury [ __ ] if he got
injured now like that he would've been
healed in a second but technology wasn't
like that bad everybody like afternoon
Iowa Grant Hill Oh Harold miner for some
reason and a wife's member Disney
because they say he was like maybe
Jordan I don't remember that yeah I
don't remember how you played I just
remember they called him baby Jordan and
he never ever lived up to that dude i I
had the [ __ ] the pennies the shoes
the big plague yeah circular yeah my
brother had at first and I think they
had like that a reflector if you sound
like a light on it I think it was on air
it's just as air on the side it's a huge
[ __ ] yeah but for Jordan shoes the 1
the 3 the 5s and the 11s were my
favorite Jornal Evans it's the the
patent leather red and white ones the
breads those were my favorite ones and
then fives are the one that are built
like a boot and then ones are the
classic ones that everybody bites that
everybody bites the model of what the
one looks like everybody does because
now that shows I was banned from the NBA
it was bad it was banned yeah it was bad
because he didn't follow code like
because everyone's wearing the same shoe
yeah like they were wearing all that
convertion and then my friend does he
produced this documentary called unban
the story of the a1 saying like it just
looked weird in unison with everyone
else playing like he had these and like
it's such a crazy strategy design-wise
like it was bright red
black and he's just stood it out I'd be
really dope yeah it feels like that
crazy converse commercial is like yeah
there that that that didn't like the
shoes like oh [ __ ] hip hop and Run DMC
is coming in town they ate you know
adidas had their own things like I want
that and so and B it was like no we're
gonna ban that shoot mm-hmm and then
Nike was like well how much does the fee
if every time cuz if they said like if
Jordan were as it continues to wear that
shoe were gonna find him like ten
thousand five thousand dollar but no
Nikes like fine okay so Franco I think
for a whole season they just kept paying
it over and over and over and then
people were like oh [ __ ] this is the on
bench like this is the bandhas shoe yeah
I want it so that's what drove cells
crazy cuz people are trying to get it oh
is that why they have that Jordan won
unbanned they have a model yeah yeah
yeah yeah I sold that [ __ ] mm-hmm oh so
that's what that meant
yeah I was so out of the shoot game I
understand any of this yeah cuz it came
as such a kook again like a kismet
lightning bolt moment where like hip hop
was that you know it's very conscious
hip hop was coming into fruition and and
and the league was coming popular and
then yeah Jordan
fresh those shoes are so [ __ ] icon I
still have a lot of my Jordans on
majority the stuff I sold I got on I
don't have a lot a ones are iconic day
ones yeah yeah I those they're so
[ __ ] iconic man like I still have if
I were to label the shoes that I still
have left I have my I have the bread
Elevens I have my Chicago ones I have
the the bread ones I have the grape
fives I have the the fire red the fire
red agree what this look like yeah
there's a cool The Fresh Prince mmm
right I got the actual The Fresh Prince
fires that was like the new one that
came out I thought that was so [ __ ]
dope had that [ __ ] it's a little loud
for me now am I still rocking depending
on how I feel right and then I sold all
my threes which I regret but you know at
the time I needed the money uh because I
was you know transitioning getting an
office so I was like [ __ ] just where
the stuff you're never gonna wear or
sell the stuff you're never gonna wear
and I've sold them but now they're worth
like [ __ ] 600 bucks I'm like [ __ ] god
dammit yeah but I still have the door
does that mean a lot to me mmm yeah I'll
have the tax because I have a few other
stuff too but
amen like it's crazy how back in the day
if you wanted the Dornish you just go
and buy it yeah
wait for a [ __ ] raffle yeah dump it's
completely dumb yeah I missed that date
we just go in and buy just go anyone was
high like there's like life in the
stores and this whole manufactured wake
up hey mom can you go away in this line
get this raffle tickets like [ __ ] me
like this shoe is rare like rare how you
could just get the spec and making a
[ __ ] factory like what was so rare
about this [ __ ] I understand when
something's like discontinued and you
know it was during that year I get the
how that [ __ ] works yeah just the
concept that I can't get a shoe when I
want it it's so dumb to me and I was one
of those like sneaker as you remember I
had stacks of shoes everywhere right
here could be my shoes like it ah man
yeah I raise all the time like but like
the locker I'm like like we couldn't
find these things online like we had to
at least we had to see it on someone's
feet I'm gonna look in the East Bay
catalog or something in the newspaper
like that's just just like looking for
it what about East Bay man yeah man just
like oh my god this is coming out
[ __ ] next catalog or whatever no you
guys used to pay I remember I used to
get the East Bay catalogs and I would
just look during lunch I'll just go
through it yeah I'll bring those
magazines to lunch I just looked at it
like this is the new East Bay magazine
let's see what a cop yeah and I were
specifically remember me buying three
Chuck Taylors right cuz it was three of
those shoes for like 25 bucks at the
foot it was that cheap in high school oh
[ __ ] you can get three of them for like
20 bucks or 30 bucks and no one knew
nobody saw yeah oh these are dope
they're like the original basketball
shoes and you know so at that time
converse wasn't bought by Nike so Nike
actually bought out converse and they
not Nike tech to converse so that's why
you see like converse with Nike soles
and all the other stuff and got a lot
more comfortable date but that's they
remarketed them and they rebranded them
and they started getting the popping
also too because of that punk rock scene
they were wearing those conversation
Rises like the way they look and I got
three converse for like 25 bucks and I
remember two years after that they were
like 50 bucks a pop mm I was like how
the [ __ ] are these this expensive these
are cheap ass shoes cuz it's literally
just a canvas and it's uncomfortable as
Sol yeah it's it's [ __ ] insane yeah I
didn't know that
that Nike was bought out converse yeah
and the converse was the original
basketball shoe that wouldn't allow Nike
to shine and they bought out the [ __ ]
company talk about a [ __ ] Power Move
dude yeah and then insane plus so dope I
so dough for some reason I remember that
my first basketball [ __ ] was dr. J's
anyway you went dr. J's yeah I did my
have a choice yeah my dad's like this is
a good player look at this clip oh man
we goddamn shoes yeah look at him scoop
okay yeah [ __ ] women when did you get
picked up to play a pro ball how old
were you semi-pro that's 22 so what what
categorizes something a semi-pro well
what is that just not the leak like that
like well you could be considered a
amateur yeah there's a professional
amateur professional is like like the
NBA yeah you know cuz even in certain
parts in Europe like Sean xx Parker's
team like all of that it's like I'm
pretty sure their league is like the
amateur league and it just took a
different scheduling in terms of games
mmm of games scheduling that's really it
in the game so for me like it was like a
season or like seat like a season in
terms of like three months or two months
and then a quick turnaround and then a
different like that team would going to
a different so was almost like we knew
when you go to like you know high school
tournaments like before I put the
preseason that's what it felt like to me
so yeah 22 is about when I went well
before that I paid plague in the winter
Taiwan and then three years ago after
that I can't remember why I broke up
yeah three years after that si I want to
Whittier didn't work out and then Costa
Rica and then I was like what's it
is it true what's the training like for
that [ __ ] yeah that hard I'm Emily
cuz I I've seen like Doc's on like
football training and stuff but I don't
know what basketball conditioning is
like aside from a few stuff where Mike
was like I'm not gonna get punked by
these pistons anymore yeah work out some
way 20 pounds of [ __ ] muscle and this
will got jacked here jacked yeah I mean
it's like it came back that nation I can
demolish of the milestone get the [ __ ]
off my court yeah so dough that's part
of that dock is when Pippen got fouled
[ __ ] hard he sat down no emotion yeah
all right and you just destroy yeah
journos like my new pip didn't say
anything he's [ __ ] pissed
yeah that [ __ ] was tight now a super
dope I miss dad just [ __ ] pushing
people to the floor I don't think people
realize how aggressive basketball was
yeah man you know you know the newer
generation they don't they haven't seen
that so they don't understand why for me
one of the biggest reasons why I stopped
watching basketball so much was because
the game changed a lot and it was
everything everybody's just trying to
dunk twenty four [ __ ] seven and me
now now and then three three stuff the
flop and the fouling oh yeah he just it
just stops the game and it's just come
on like let's go let's go let's go let's
go to flop in the game is like it's yeah
the game has changed in terms of like
officiating what's being let go hmm it's
like now that the game has evolved into
these new rules now he's played these
new school players have to adopt to
these and use it to their advantage and
yeah use it as it like a flap is a
tactic like that's so that's so weird
cuz I grew up in the 90s or you know was
a hand checking I guess yeah though hand
check is not allowed whatsoever which I
didn't know like you know when you play
street ball [ __ ] you start doing that
[ __ ] yes I get mad yeah you can't do
that right get to what right hand
checking me right now trust me where you
going I think they took that way when
Jordan was playing cuz even then he was
like okay cool
if you don't mean handshake but you know
what's interesting about that too there
was there's there's an offense to the
use had checking to your advantage you
just have to wait for them to put
pressure to try
shift your weight and then you go the
opposite way oh yeah there's a way to
stop handshake yes you see the Navy all
the time if that was allowed and then
that's how we're going to learn how to
incorporate this hand checking into the
game that I was taken away how we're
gonna adjust floppy floppy yep
flapping or phantom fouls Oh does Mac in
the face like you've never see them yes
being classic films people were getting
punched yeah
and that's when jaws Sally was like if
you're gonna foul [ __ ] foul like him
out take him out yeah
like Dee sticky tech he's like yeah yeah
so hard why didn't realize that the
handshaking was the evolution of
everything else that's so [ __ ] crazy
because I just when when they took that
away I was like the big [ __ ] deal
right so that's when the flopping
happened hmm that's so [ __ ] odd man
yeah I mean I'm a sacrament kingdom
above la dee dee Bob that's loppers baby
farted on his ankle this fool just like
what the [ __ ] you're so good at that
[ __ ] dude I remember Jackie's get mad at
him flopping yep so well I don't
remember that's it he would remember to
it was just the those phantom felts
where you would just lean into the shot
uh yeah and then you would pick up the
fella it's just the most [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass way to play ball dude I hated that
[ __ ] it's like foul no flopping flopping
and just leaning into a FAL just jump
shouting into somebody oh yeah yeah like
studying film where I know that if you
play defense I know your head you're
consistently doing this mm-hmm I'm gonna
line up my shot in there like a lock up
and yeah I felt like him and Dirac James
Harden me all dressed shit's like like
you said it stops the game it stops the
game he's just done like come on just
play so you're that bad I'm a [ __ ]
player yeah you've got bad of a [ __ ]
your play you try to play one-on-one
Kevin Durant Kevin Durant you're trash
bro I've never seen such a trash ass
player you fool good hop instead of a
hey I'm a big fan though Kevin remember
I'm just making funnies yeah yeah it's
it's it's weird it's it's but I I
appreciate it I don't know I just missed
the old I do oh for sure
[Laughter]
domina will can slam it off
[ __ ] be like in your face suck
my dick [ __ ] and then go to the other
side of the court
yeah deal with that [ __ ] you little
punk-ass [ __ ] yeah she was tight yeah
let me see Jordan was like oh don't hold
him back don't hold him back when him
and Reggie were fighting yeah it all
back yeah let him go let it go
it would never allow this year oh yeah
we sound like some old-ass heads right
now they don't do it like I mean it's
just like they was a technology like I
remember like like the I would watch the
pregame my people are watching preview
but the pregame was sewed oh yeah like
there's such a aliveness to it and like
seen it on the TV and like kids are
outside and people someone someone has a
hoop nearby and you're shooting in
you're like what time is it
oh [ __ ] tip-off all right cool cool yeah
halftime and then come back and shoot
our hoops with your friends during
halftime be like who you going for I was
I'm going you four Utah's like not
Jordan man we're going six rings but
yeah I like like no no no like it's
Utah's years whatever it like it's hard
to really fall in love with a team now
because of how contracts are built and
how things are traded yes people don't
live and die with the team anymore they
live and die by the big neck yeah
paycheck it's all paycheck it's like
yeah well this place is gonna play me
pay me more than allow me to be a star
so I'm gonna go which which sucks right
because I I do understand that you know
everybody wants to wring you know that's
that's really important but there's
great NBA players who never got a ring
or considered legends in this game and
they're not defined by that [ __ ] ring
right but you know I like Kobe to cope
he could have gone anywhere else but he
stayed in Lakers even when Lakers was
trash he stayed Yeah right and he was
the captain of that team any [ __ ]
stayed yeah I wish I wish Nash would
have stayed with Phoenix all the way
through ah ethic yeah but then he threw
out his back lifting up his duffle bag
oh yeah you looked it up his duffle bag
in the gym and he thought it was it and
he was like I'm too old for this [ __ ]
now - was amazing on the Phoenix Suns
dude you know what the crazy did you
hear about that rumor that old old rumor
about LeBron and Dwayne and DeRose mm-hm
yeah that was that was supposed to
happen like 2010
oh really yeah gosh didn't
if bashed in a tree sign I think it was
or didn't it I think he was already
there no no he wasn't there cuz they all
came at the same time it was something
about like if Troy if didn't if Iran if
Washington say that he was even from
Toronto to go to Miami LeBron and D Way
would have been like cuz they were
already talking about going to Chicago
to joined heroes because that's crazy
what it worked that way so they would
have statistically like I saw like the
team it could have potentially been
better than the Bulls that showcase over
the last dance that have been [ __ ]
crazy it was like Mike baby I think he
was on the team my baby was in Chicago
and they would have been DeRose and it
wasn't like LeBron James and the Kyle
Korver any weight is my favorite and be
a player of all time yeah all time for
me any was from what I remember like I
love D way number one he came into the
league a lot older and this was I'm
talking about this is like during the
Carmelo Anthony it was Carmelo Anthony D
Wade and LeBron they were like 33 Kings
right it's like who's [ __ ] better and
people would choose their players my
brothers stuck with Carmelo Anthony mr.
[ __ ] Carmelo Anthony a fan too man but
you did not live up to your hype he did
not go hey man yeah he just I don't he
doesn't have the he has the ability but
doesn't have the mentality of Kobe Yeah
right it's like you could see a lot of
greatness in a lot of this is from
something coming from an outside just a
fan of the sport like Cartman nobody's
gonna ever say Karma Carmelo Anthony's
trash he's not he's dope but I think his
mind is weak and if people can see it
like mentally he's not as strong as
these other people he's not out there
willing to [ __ ] die to grab that ball
see it when he plays and that's why I
don't like him that much like I don't
see that that that willingness that
spirit I don't see him getting angry
you know maybe whining but that's not
nothing day in and day out
mmm I like Kobe like end it you know you
don't see it I mean I'm never watching
the game when Denver and Lakers were in
the finals or not finals whatever
western western semi-finals and there
was like going at it like I'm [ __ ]
Carmela is like really giving it to Kobe
like yeah but that's when he was in the
Olympics he showed how dope he was
sinking three he's like a [ __ ]
Mike
the competitive Carmel meeting that were
they yeah and they just never happened
but Dwayne Wade he reminded me of Jordan
how he would bang up his body or any
[ __ ] point possible like a people
were talking about his crazy shots just
over the bat you know random sure that's
very Jordan s and so he reminded me of a
resurgence of Jordan the most even more
than then Kobe did for me I know a lot
of people think that's crazy
more than Kobe just from how how he
would handle the ball and how he would
get these points in the most awkward
situations reminded me of Jordan and I
think if you combined Kobe and Wade
together that would have been who Jordan
was right just how he would attack the
hoop but then you have like the
mentality that mama mentality and then
he has Jordans fade doesn't combine
those two [ __ ] style together that
would have been Jordan right there yeah
because it it takes it takes uh Kobe's
discipline like Kobe's very like
calculated I'm very strategic about how
he's gonna shoot and attack the defender
or whatever but Dwyane Wade is this
slashing all over place doing it enough
fall on the floor he's in the tourists
were like I'm not tourists but famous
print like it down for getting who kept
on the fifth or whatever the hell that
clutch yes clutch every time yeah if you
guys if you guys want to just look up
any of like just look at Wayne weight
highlights and you'll see how [ __ ]
insane he was yeah I gotta watch this
thirty four thirty yeah I'm gonna watch
that [ __ ] too
but the only way I respected him a lot
because of I forgot I don't think it was
thirty four thirty but it's a small doc
and he was just talking about how he
grew up hmm and like his part of Chicago
and how [ __ ] terrible it was he goes I
used to walk down the street as a kid
and you would see dead bodies and
garbage cans like that was my existence
growing up as a child to be able to do
what I do now like this is this is the
reality that had to escape and now you
know to see how he is now he married
Gabrielle Union she's a lot older than
him right I think so yeah yeah and they
have a [ __ ] a little [ __ ] attacking
a Dwayne Wade
uh Oh kid about his that his child is
transitioning into a daughter or yes
yeah so she's a she's a it's a she but
she's a she's a she now yeah but that's
what a little boozy he was coming at him
he's like twenty wait it's a boy you
remember that [ __ ] uh it's a little boo
see he went on Instagram while he's in
Planet Fitness and by the way Planet
Fitness ban lil boosie from coming in
after that video and he's sitting here
just going on there's moral rant about
why Dwyane Wade is wrong about allowing
his child to be listen I think a lot of
people agreed with lil boosie actually
in terms of like you know a child
psychology and allowing them to choose
their gender when they're not even a
fully when their brain hasn't even fully
developed yet allow them to do what they
do and explore mmm but maybe not you
know encourage what you think that they
should do that is right because it's
politically correct
it's allow kids to explore and then
they'll figure out for themselves when
they're older because it seems like
they're kind of young but of course Lil
Boosie didn't say that they'll boo see
didn't say that out loud he goes oh wait
that's a boy is what he was doing on it
and I'm like little boo see you you do
realize your name is lil boosie bro yeah
the [ __ ] wants to hear life advice
because I got a raise a child dog is
either one but his nephews the ones he
paid like some hooker yes Oh exactly he
went to jail for a hot minute he only
got out not too long ago for that I know
it was for that but he got he basically
got his underaged nephew like a bunch of
strippers to [ __ ] slap [ __ ] on his
lap it's what I call it that's what I
call lap dance lap and [ __ ] on the lap
slapping on a lap yeah so you want to
talk about the moral high ground about
how to raise a kid though what you're
saying i whatever you know trace amount
of truth is in there you are not the
person to ever lay an opinion about how
to raise a child properly your name is
lil boosie shut the [ __ ] up
you know and that's what everybody was
saying it's like dude who the [ __ ] are
you going over here yelling in Planet
Fitness of all the places like he's
screamin and Planet Fitness
hey mr. strip club before yep yeah no
I'm not I have that's the one thing I
haven't done
I've never been interested yeah I mean
either I picked up my friend one of my
teammates I picked him up for the strip
club once hey so you should come on one
next time like nah man he's like look at
my pants I'm like what about your pants
but you know his pants no I hear black
like slacks on it
looked like a snail was like like
chowing down Schlage I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] lay that's disgusting that's
[ __ ] disgusting dude you don't know
where that lady's been yeah and you just
had [ __ ] juice all he was like smell it
baby this right here I told you slapping
[ __ ] on last dude I told you my
descriptions are accurate and [ __ ] on
left what the [ __ ] I look like a snail
was just left this [ __ ] juice trail
on his leg he was just cool with it yeah
what the [ __ ] and he was like proud look
yeah you see this turn on light
[ __ ] laughs in your pants
you see this yeah you shoulda Schmidt
ain't no snails snails d-dad that right
there don't listen [ __ ] I never I never
I mean I wouldn't say I wasn't super
interested but I never had an
inclination to go to a strip club I'm
pretty sure like a you know one of the
boys wants to go to strip club you know
for a bachelor party nobody
I don't like something's gonna happen
like belly or some [ __ ]
oh my shirt shooting up the place oh you
dancing with mom main [ __ ] ya know I'm
not an initiative snail trail on my let
me smell your pants yo you see that
Tyler Perry [ __ ] series that was like
on HBO or some [ __ ] or et which one if
there's this clip right show me the [ __ ]
there's this clip of this dude saying
take off your pants
yikes and this dude takes off his pants
and he gets down and he sniffs his dick
big of a bite Tyler Perry what the [ __ ]
are you writing I'm gonna show you this
[ __ ] and it's real if you write so cool
that's the teaser that's just a cliff if
you type on Twitter a Tyler Perry Dick
Smith and you'll see this dude come on
take off your pants here takes up his
pants and imprison his dicks out no it's
like in a junkyard a car junkyard and
then God goes down he goes comes up
real close to his face he goes down he
goes swish the dick he goes and that's
the same thing he sniffs the big I never
said this deal I gotta say no bro that's
right as I haven't seen it yeah it's
just weird dude lost his [ __ ] mind
man he writes for the people I'm trying
to figure out whose demographic is
Atlanta Alana's storage bin and Walmart
it's kind of those people if Tyler Perry
came up to you and he goes Khalifa I
want to give you the lead role in my
film right all right it's a Christmas
special and it's called Madea Goes to
Israel okay right you're gonna need you
to play an Israeli military guy that
checks people to see if they have bombs
by sniffing dicks and then when you go
to smell but these day you surprised
that she has a dick and it's mine who
take that roll the roll is for $20,000
and we're gonna shoot in the summer in
Israel yeah for two months Madea Goes to
Israel would I do it yeah this man right
here desperate
[Laughter]
I would a lot of things that I would do
for $20,000 oh [ __ ]
let's think about the art the art I find
more than that yeah I did some scrip
analysis on that I'll turn that [ __ ] up
did you see a descriptive analysis I put
some layers on it but it's full just
like okay well I'm not gonna grab this
dick yeah not gonna grab it Cleve I need
to grab dick what's my motivation here
this penis did you see that was it was
it a Monique that had a problem with
Tyler Perry I don't know no work I don't
know anymore oh I forgot what definite
are Perry there's definitely Leo's
Butler it was Lee Daniels was it so Lee
Daniels was the one that that approached
Monique with the hole because Lee
Daniels did precious yeah right the
precious is all about to call the film
precious purple is called precious right
and so Monique Monique played a very
integral role in the film I never
actually got to see precious yet here
isn't it I haven't seen it but I'm sure
that clearly she runs the chicken and
run yes okay keep going
it was amazing without any context of
what that film is think but his things
I've ever seen in my life
I do like I was like what the thing even
this clip is really done yes very deep
yes based on so many years to the
culture I've been feeding her child yeah
but the fact that she's still in fried
chicken is hilarious yeah it's pretty
bad that's what that's pretty [ __ ]
terrible
yeah and so I guess Monique was offered
a role on the film right yeah and you
know she was kind of to her account what
she was saying she was I was taken aback
because of Oh Lee Daniels wants me to
work on this art piece this is amazing
well she got paid wasn't much money
right there wasn't a back-end about her
having to program up to promote the film
but she has like all these like email
receipts or whatever whatnot but what it
kind of boiled down to was
after she kind of played the role and
this is before Oprah heard of the film
or anything else she he kind of put it
into words that either was through an
interview or was an email that Monique's
role was to kind of get eyes on the film
and she fulfilled that role is that oh I
thought it was because you told me that
I was gonna be something special to this
[ __ ] character hmm
right so she you know that's pretty
[ __ ] offensive I'd be [ __ ]
offended by that right because the story
behind the Hollywood of anything that
has to do with Monique is the fact that
she's a very difficult person that
monique is difficult she's hard to deal
with she's allowed or whatever but
Monique's argument to that is that you
could say whatever you want about me
right I'm loud I'm obnoxious I'm highly
opinionated but one thing you can never
say about me is I'm a [ __ ] liar and I
do not lie and um with the whole the
whole Lee Daniels thing and I think Lee
Daniels is cancelled right now right Lee
Dan's can't do [ __ ] really
I don't forgot what he did he might have
touched the baby or something really I
don't know I don't know what it is he
might have got me to tore some [ __ ]
but what she was saying about in his
case was you know she felt kind of used
right and that that was the case and
then he was upset at her because she
wouldn't do like promos and tours which
wasn't written in the contract and
saying that she was difficult and you
know this is the story that this is the
rhetoric that happens around Monique a
lot right and then there was that
conversation with Anika and Steve Harvey
if you watch The Steve Harvey Show in
the oh and that show that they go at it
dude and not not added as is screaming
at each other but they're on two
opposite ends mm-hmm so monique is
talking about a lot of prominent black
people in entertainment lost their way
and they kind of lost their integrity
they see they say she says that it feels
like a lot of black people in
entertainment and I'm paraphrasing right
now are still in that survival mode of
like I should be grateful that anybody
wants to [ __ ] with me anyway it's and
anybody wants to give me a paycheck to
do this role she was for for how long
how long am I supposed to do this how
long am I supposed to feel grateful that
I'm lucky to have this role rather than
this is a role for me and I should get
paid what I deserve I've been in this
industry for a very long time I know my
wait I know my I know my power so what
the [ __ ] right and the Steve is like
that's not how you play the game because
I got children to feed I got all this
other stuff and it kind of made like
uncle Steve Steve seemed like Uncle Tom
yeah right it's like oh you just here
chasing Aston dollars
right but I think what Steve was trying
to the [ __ ] was that oh is that the the
battery going out on the [ __ ] monitor
some [ __ ] knows but either way but
Monique was talking about how you know
that's that's not a very there's no
integrity in that right she goes I'm
tired of doing this [ __ ] I'm tired of
having to just chase this almighty
dollar and just kind of bow out and kind
of do what everybody else asked me to do
just because I should be grateful for
these [ __ ] roles and then you know
because she went
I guess that camera is also out too
either way just gonna be wider here but
um what Monique was saying - with Oprah
and the whole Oprah situation she got
super upset by opening she got really
teary especially when talking about and
she also wants an apology from Oprah
Winfrey and Whoopi Goldberg and this was
like a couple years ago by the way
because what be said to her behind doors
it's like you know what like you're
worried your stance on this stuff is
that you want to make a stance because
you're worried about the generations
before they come after you right and you
know standing up for them well here's
the thing he's like just worry about
yourself don't worry about them worry
about yourself and that broke her heart
she goes because oh what about all these
other prominent black woman before me
that came before it became before us and
said I'm just gonna worry about myself
and not worry about the future where
would I be what would I be where would
you be right and you're somebody that
should stand up for more than just this
and you're okay just looking after your
back and saying [ __ ] you to the rest of
the to everybody else and she was my
heart was broken she also mentioned like
when she had a conversation with Oprah
and she confronted Oprah and I said like
you know you owe me an apology long
story short about that was that this is
this is Monique telling this story
Oprah was gonna do this whole special
about her [ __ ] up family situation
right she wasn't have her mom on or
whatever and she goes no I don't want
you to do that right but instead of
having her mom on and her and her mom on
she just brought her whole family on
there without telling her about it and
so she thought they had a mutual respect
saying like oh I don't want anything
don't don't put up my family business
out there but then Oprah went ahead and
did it anyways without Monique being
there but she brought her family on
and that caused a lot of drama in her
life and she felt [ __ ] disrespected
and so she confronted Oprah about that
and then basically what she told her so
you owe me an apology and then what
Oprah said was that if you feel like I
did something wrong to you I completely
apologized which is not a [ __ ]
apology of course and she didn't feel
right about that stuff and you know what
she what Monique told Oprah was hey like
I remember when I was a young fat black
girl and I looked up to you and I said
and I saw you on TV and I said there's
another fat black woman people respect
and love her I want to be just like you
and I don't a field trip she went to go
see her and then um you know she was
inspired as she told her told that to
her as a young little girl I think
whenever I let's say she was eight years
old and then later on when she started
popping off and became a famous she
talked to her and then Oprah said
something to her that stuck with her
that helped her as she goes the reason
why I like you so much it's because I
see a younger version of myself in you
and it empowered her and someone she
confronted that about that stuff she
goes well what does that say about you
when you did all this stuff so I
remember that time when you told me that
you saw a younger self of you you and me
so I want to make sure that I keep you
in check and let you know that this is
wrong she goes sweetie I say that to
everybody
mm-hmm [ __ ] yeah could you imagine it's
like uh saying I saved that single
phrase to everybody yeah and she was
wrecked you know and so she said feels
like she deserves an apology from Tyler
Perry and all this other stuff and I I
agree too you know on the political
scale is it a good move but you know
what is what is Monique have to prove
now right
besides you know sending up an example
and showing people what's up she goes I
don't respect these [ __ ] what
they did like I love them they're my
brothers like we're we're cool however
this is how I feel about this situation
so it's a wrong that I feel that you
guys did and I feel like you did I
deserve an apology from the way that you
treated me Holly was [ __ ] crazy man
do you mean it could be friends I think
I'm scared of her you talked me into
believing [ __ ] that I don't believe
right but the reason why I like her is
because I think she's very good at
proving her point sometimes I feel like
she says she she understeers she
understands and hears you but she
doesn't you don't just wants to get her
point across but I do agree with her but
what I have been bold enough to do what
she didn't know right because I'm not in
her position but I think
she's in a position where she can't
speak up against it people were upset at
her about her Netflix deal because
number one she felt slighted about it
but I think her point was that why can't
I feel slighted about this money that I
feel that I deserve right the whole boy
I think Charlamagne tha God had a whole
issue with it because he says that his -
his argument is that at this point you
don't deserve dave chappelle money
because you can't bring in dave
chappelle numbers mm-hmm right facts i
think that's [ __ ] facts right it's
hard that does anybody that's just
that's not just monique right but she
goes if if I walk into this Netflix
meeting right and they say to me hey
you're a legend you're the female Dave
Chappelle you're on that type of status
right and then I come back away and then
you go well we're gonna give you
$500,000 when you offer Dave Chappelle
50 60 million that's what she said they
said they told her she told the offer to
offer was five hundred thousand dollars
right and she goes well that doesn't
make sense for me
number one is offensive number two I
have to do this stand-up and I have to
go on tour I can't use this material
it's it's up on this TV screen so this
has to make I'll make about two three
mil yeah doing my regular stuff but I'm
not gonna be able to form this so she
should at least match that and they're
like well we can't do that it's like
that's highly offensive it's super
offensive yeah I actually agreed with
her I was like that when she said five
hundred thousand I was like five hundred
thousand that's it like his [ __ ]
Monique and she does have a huge fan
base right
she's definitely worth more than five
hundred thousand at least a [ __ ] mil
for [ __ ] crying out loud
if you need a Chappelle sixty million
you could hear it could give Monique a
million dollars to mid to cover up the
suspension that she would lose from
doing that right and uh it's it's in her
right to feel offended by that you know
the whole boycott thing I'm not too sure
if I'm on that side mm-hmm and then her
suing Netflix I think that's a little
weird
yeah right but forget the whole she's
not a monolith that's for sure she's for
sure
he's a all kinds of black person she
scared me though yeah yeah that's well
uh that wraps up this episode went
through a lot of things we talked about
the last time our shoes without Monique
type Monique as we're talking about a
whole bunch of stuff man
[ __ ] yeah um well you guys can catch
this podcast on every audio platform out
there one day I'll be like Joe Rogan
where Spotify offers me two hundred
million dollars but the funny thing is
I'm already putting my stuff up on
Spotify so they wouldn't think must take
yourself to oh no I hurt radio somebody
sign me man
Apple yeah well thank you for listening
into the genius brain podcast we started
out this [ __ ] you could catch us
on every single audio platform you can
find Khalifa at Khalifa Boyd on
Instagram yeah follow me follow me a
dear I'm lonely yeah Oh God no not that
kind of lonely I just want conversation
I'll set him dicks right now do not send
him that video clip that dude kissing
that dick is saying that could be you
that could be us well you guys we'll
catch y'all next time and peace out
peace